this is the poco f4 gt and i now
strongly believe that this is the best
value mobile gaming phone out there on
the market because it only costs around
630 dollars so in this video i'm gonna
compare it to the iphone 13 pro max
which starts at eleven hundred dollars
to see if this phone can beat the iphone
in terms of overall gaming performance
and the reason i believe this poco phone
is so good is because it's literally
engineered for gaming it has built-in
triggers that you can use to shoot and
do whatever you want you can customize
it it has dual vapor chamber cooling
they even moved the charging controller
away from the chip so that it doesn't
heat up your chip while you're gaming
they optimized everything as much as
they could for gaming performance so
what we're gonna do in this video is
play three different games we're going
to play of course gentian impact the
brand new apex mobile legends and we're
going to play pubg new state and to find
out which one has better fps i actually
have perf dog open right here so this is
going to monitor and show the fps in
real time as i'm playing the game so
before we jump into what i want to
mention that i matched up the brightness
to around 80
on both of these phones so it's
completely fair and we'll get to see if
any of these start dimming or having any
other issues so let's jump right into it
alright so here i am with the iphone 13
pro max in apex legends and you might
notice that i have it plugged in using
the lightning to usb c cable to the
macbook pro and that's because we want
to be able to see if it hits up to 120
fps or 90. but before we begin i want to
go into the settings and show you guys
the graphics and as you can see i've set
the frame rate to extreme to make sure
we're maxing it out and unfortunately it
brings down the graphics quality to
normal in order to have the frame rate
set to extreme but with that said let's
go ahead and get into a match and test
it out i'm going to go ahead and start
the recording it looks like it's
averaging about
80 fps right now it's interesting is it
limited to 80 it's kind of weird
got him 80 fps i wonder why it's 80 and
not 90. i mean it doesn't make sense and
i can also see on the actual phone on
the iphone it says 80 as well so i guess
that's the limit
oh you guys see that the iphone just
dimmed and that is pretty bad honestly
it is more difficult now to see it and i
feel the heat on my phone i mean the
thing is it is plugged in so it's also
charging but i have to have it plugged
in
to be able to uh record 120 and honestly
that was after about uh eight minutes of
gaming after eight minutes oh there he
is
you down
what's up
this is fun
steal it 80 fps
very consistent still dim so it has not
recovered
got him all right so the iphone is still
dimmed fortunately all right we did it
yeah that was pretty fun stayed at 80
but the display did dim so that's the
biggest downside other than that
everything was flawless with the iphone
still dimmed right now all right and
here we are on the poco f4 gt and i just
love how gamer focused this is because
you could actually see the triggers
right here and you could actually
receive them back into the phone with
those switches not only that but all of
the speakers are up at the top of the
phone you're holding it like this and
the antennas are actually built around
you holding it like this while gaming so
that you don't block the wi-fi signal
this is just incredible all right this
phone is nice and bright colors look
good but it looks like the fps is kind
of dropping actually let me make sure to
turn that on there you go it's starting
to record and it looks like we're
sitting at 60 fps but it's not
consistent it actually does dip down
okay now let me show you guys this cool
little menu as you can see you can see
this bar right here just swipe out and
you see all your gpu cpu information
your fps performance but you can set up
your shoulder button so
let me set the right one for shooting
right there and the left one i'm going
to set for aiming all right aiming and
shooting ah
that's so cool
okay we got that set up let's go
dude oh i love these triggers
[Music]
yes sucks you can't get 90 uh on android
on apex i'm scared there's two verse one
got him
yeah 49 50 fps it actually dropped down
to 50. i mean we're getting a solid 80
on the iphone right i'm starting to feel
this phone really heat up and it's been
sitting at solid 50
so it literally clocked itself down no
longer getting 60 fps oh it came down to
40 fps
we did it oh right at the end it went
down to 40. you can see it down clocked
itself to 40 fps right there they call
this a gaming oh what so i feel the heat
really bad this thing is hot just like
the iphone however
it did not dim like the iphone that is a
positive but it went all the way down to
a solid 40. it down clocked itself
alright guys so with apex gaming out of
the way we can actually go to perfdog
and check out the actual stats between
these two phones so first of all we have
the iphone it got 79.2
fps so really really good and then if we
go over to the poco 53 53.7
average fps so it's quite a bit worse in
terms of the fps but at least it didn't
dim as much and of course i love those
triggers oh they are so fun so now let's
jump into the next game alright so i'm
on the iphone this is pub g
new state let's jump into the settings
and graphics let's set it to 90 fps and
unfortunately it makes me go all the way
down to
light graphics quality to turn 90 on but
that's okay because 90 is worth it let's
go ahead and jump into the game all
right here we are in pubg and
unfortunately it says 60 fps is it
really limited to 60 graphics max what
happens if i go max still at 60 kind of
doesn't make sense
tell me i can get this dude
oh it's like my last hit let me try to
go to the graphics settings and turn on
90 again still at 60.
got him
[Music]
see it's kind of like hard to hit that
little aim button all right so we just
passed around 11 minutes on the iphone
playing pubg new state and it's been
basically around 60 and it has dipped
down a little bit but it's been pretty
consistent so i'm gonna go ahead and
stop this and switch over to the poco
all right check this out unfortunately
it says that if i'm using usb debugging
mode which is what i need for perf dog
then new state may not execute properly
and unfortunately i've tried it a couple
of times
and it looks like it's just not gonna
run so sadly we won't be able to use
perf dog to compare the stats between
the two phones but i do know that the
iphone played at a solid 60 fps and
there was no screen dimming or any
issues so we'll base it off of that now
i do want to mention that i'm gonna keep
it plugged in so it's fair just like the
iphone was also charging from the
macbook pro now with that said let's go
ahead and adjust the shoulder buttons
let's put right right there so
we're shooting and let's do aim oh i
love this so much and i do want to
mention i'm doing the max frame rate
option with the graphics set to ultra
and let's set this to high as well cool
thing is i could actually see the fps on
the actual game
mode menu so it's sitting at a pretty
solid 60fps right now and there you go
you can see it's still staying at 60fps
no dimming so no issues at all with pubg
new state and i think the gaming
performance is the same between the two
but of course this has the trigger so
really really nice and now let's go
ahead and go to the iphone playing game
chan impact let's go into the settings
and basically max everything out that i
could set the fps to 120 yes you can
play 120 fps genshin on the iphone 13
pro and pro max let's go all right so we
do have some spikes that go up to 120
but look at that it actually goes down
back to like 50 so it can't handle that
fps look at that okay back to 90 back to
60 boom
all right let's go
oh
that's a bad idea i'm scared
it looks like oh we just did like crazy
i could hardly see anything the display
dimmed just like an apex but now in
gentian it did it so much more quickly
because uh 120 fps support you know all
right so uh it is hot but i saw it spike
up again
it only goes up in fps for like a slight
bit oh this fps is going down i feel the
phone it's so hot too 45 fps man this is
not good so this phone can't really
handle heat that well unfortunately the
iphone and it's just dropping frames all
over the place all right now that we're
over eight minutes playing man the fps
is suffering it's down to 46 48 no
longer even solid 60 which is very
disappointing on this iphone so i guess
that 120 fps mode literally does not
matter it looks like the display is
still dim all right and there you go we
just passed 10 minutes so i'm gonna go
ahead and stop this
save it and let's play on the poco all
right and now i'm on the poco in the
graphic settings in genjen i've set
everything to as high as it can go
unfortunately it goes up to 60 fps so it
does not support 120. right now i'm
curious to see how the fps is going to
react and respond
as i start fighting right now it's
around uh 40 45 oh i got to use these
triggers man whoa it's actually a little
bit weird compared to like an fps
shooter starting to feel the back of the
phone heat up that's for sure oh and we
are dipping i just saw 37 right there
fps is dipping all right so for uh this
type of game like genshin it's not good
to have these set like it's not as nice
maybe if you set it to something else
maybe like dodging actually shoulder
button on the left will be dodge that's
actually nice oh the fps is suffering 37
38 now that it the phone's heating up
it's getting hot i feel those drop
frames definitely feel the drop frames
let's see how these triggers go oh
that's convenient skip
look at that you don't even need to use
your
right thumb fps is staying pretty solid
though please tell me i'm not gonna
oh i died
well that sucked well that was 10
minutes
gaming on the poco so let's go ahead and
pause this and let's go ahead and look
at the results alright wow this is
interesting even though it seemed like
the iphone was underwhelming and it was
performing really badly it actually
averaged 56.8
fps which is actually pretty good
because if you go over to the poco which
is a dedicated gaming phone with the
snapdragon 8gen1 the best chip out there
for the android phones
42.2 fps
with the poco now of course the poco did
not dim like the iphone did but the
overall fps was quite a bit lower so
if you're all for the fps then the
iphone is the clear winner across all
categories because in apex it was
getting a pretty solid 80 fps and then
in pubg new state solid 60 no dimming in
that game and then genshin let's see
56.8
which is really good for the iphone as
well while the poco struggled with fps
across all the categories which i think
is because it's limited by the
snapdragon agen one it's just not
powerful enough but in terms of all the
gaming features i'm just so impressed
that it didn't dim the controls are
really awesome those pop out controls
the left and right
crazy good for the gaming i love how the
speakers are set up i love how it's
fully dedicated and that gaming mode you
can pull out however if you're all for
the fps which i think a lot of
competitive gamers are
the iphone is still the choice that you
want to go with if you are a gamer and
it definitely wins but if you're on a
budget honestly 600 bucks for this level
of gaming performance and gaming
features is very impressive as well so
if you want to check it out i'll leave a
link to amazon down in the description
below and the pin comment hopefully you
enjoyed this video let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below and check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]